To make the audio play slowly, I accessed Help and searched for AVAudioPlayer.
Now I read through this and came across a property called Rate.
Now this variable or property is really interesting.
Because it says that its default value of 1.0 provides a normal playback rate.
All right?
And that the available range for this, is from 0.5 or
half speed playback, through 2.0 for double-speed playback.
All of this is really promising.
It goes on to say that you must first enable something called,
the Enable Rate Property.
So I can go back to my code, and set the Enable Rate Property to be true.
And then in my action, I can set the rate to let's say 0.5 for now.
Okay, let me run this project again.
I'm going to go to the second scene one more time, and
then let's click this button.
>> My mama always said, life was like a box of chocolates.
>> Nice.
Now just for kicks, I wonder what would happen if I changed this rate to 1.5.
Let me try that.
All right going to the second scene again.
>> My mama always said, life was like a box of chocolates.
>> So it seems like rate is working well.
For now, I'm going to go back and
change the rate back to 0.5 and oh, by the way,
it's a good practice to stop the audio player before we begin to play it.